the Joe Rogan experience let's talk
about that fight because that was a
crazy situation right first of all TJ
looked like dead man walking going to
the weigh-in it's like I said as bad as
anybody I've ever seen besides Travis
looter but Travis looter was a
dehydration thing TJ had starved himself
down to a skeleton it was real weird and
then when you found out that he has
taken EPO and then he said that he was
taking EPO because he just didn't have
any energy from cutting that weight I
don't I don't know man I don't know what
the answer my brother then we're talking
about that yesterday I'm not sure what
it was but I'm just I felt sick inside
when I found out you're like it's it's
like a sadness that it brings to you
because dude it's like yeah we may talk
stuff you know to each other whatnot but
it doesn't get that personal oh I
shouldn't get that personal for somebody
to take an EPO man something that a drug
that you just will never get tired and a
fight that deal with these four ounce
gloves you know what I'm saying like
there's a little bit of Malastare man so
remember that day I caught I talked to
my brother I talked to my own like [ __ ]
as thick skin that as we grew up or
whatnot I got this is her TV what would
you have done if you found out before
the fight if they gave you the option I
thought so they pulled if they pulled
you aside and said listen Henry the
fights gonna go on but we got an issue
it turns out we just got TJ's drug
sample back and he tested positive for
EPO you could still fight him if you
want to we're gonna strip them we're
gonna even if he wins we're gonna strip
oh man we're gonna find them and keep
them from fighting for two years he's
gonna get convicted of using this stuff
but you could choose to fight them just
don't tell anybody okay
but a guy can they can say like a guy
misses weight by five pounds you can
still fight you that's a [ __ ] big
advantage he didn't have to cut those
extra five you know how many times guys
miss weight and still win it's big it's
a big number when guys miss weight and
wind up winning the fight I believe who
was talking about that someone of the
one of the commentators might even
Dominick Cruz he was talking about guys
missing weight and then wind winding up
winning
the fight because they have an advantage
they didn't cut the weight they like you
we all know there's a certain point in
time what you shouldn't lose any more
weight but we also know there's a dark
land where most people don't want to
travel through we can make it through
you could get to that point where you
don't want to do anymore you're [ __ ]
dying inside
but you stay in there in extra twenty
minutes you make the weight or some
people don't but the guy who doesn't
look it's bad for your body to cut that
much weight the guy who leaves those
extra five pounds on his body that's big
yeah it is but also it is actually it is
what's bigger that repeal o EP o TG was
saying how good he felt he never felt so
good in his life I'm just saying I'm
just hearing it from him
yeah but also in that fight that's when
I thought like the most prepared Joe
like I felt even till now my career I
can retire like I'm really done and
that's the best that I've ever felt man
I guess TJ Dillashaw so I think to
answer that question I think I still
would fight him for that reason max I
did everything natural and I use science
and
[Applause]